foreign
Adobe at first glance they seem
completely harmless they simply make
software for professionals including
everything from Photoshop and to
Premiere Pro to After Effects and
illustrator they're also the ones behind
the most popular document format in the
world PDFs
as many as 2.5 trillion PDFs have been
created around the world allowing for
universally consistent formatting and
strong security and who could forget
about Adobe Flash player Adobe Flash
made some of the most classic online
games possible like the world's hardest
game and run but despite adobe's
popularity and usefulness there's
actually a massive community that
strongly despises Adobe they hate
everything from their products and the
pricing to their customer service and
the position in the market in fact
people hate Adobe so much that adobe's
trust pilot average is a disgusting out
1.2 stars with 89 of reviews being one
stars for perspective even PayPal has a
1.3 star rating with only 87 of reviews
being one Stars this is quite surprising
given that adobe isn't involved in any
of the classic about company stuff for
example they're not collecting people's
data or violating people's privacy nor
are they controlling government
officials or have access to ludicrous
amounts of power they just make a
creative software and naturally try to
make as much money as possible doing
that what makes this dichotomy even more
interesting is that adobe's corporate
sentiment is the polar opposite Adobe
isn't just a good or great employer
they're actually an exceptional employer
in fact according to Glassdoor employees
Choice Adobe CEO ranks as the second and
most approved CEO only beaten out by
Boston Consulting Group Adobe also earns
dozens of awards every single year for
having one of the most Progressive
company cultures employees like Adobe so
much that they've been able to maintain
an A plus 4.9 star rating across 24 775
employee reviews clearly I'd Adobe knows
how to handle employees that and to keep
them happy so how did Adobe go so wrong
with their customers
to really understand this dichotomy
between employees and customers we first
have to understand why customers hate
Adobe so much in the first place all of
this can be traced back to 2012 when
Adobe introduced Creative Cloud Creative
Cloud had completely uprooted adobe's
Revenue model instead of having
customers pay a large one-time licensing
fees of a 500 or 700 for a specific
version of a software they forced people
to jump onto an expensive subscription
planner which currently costs 55 per
month or 660 dollars per year for
professionals who already had licenses
to several Adobe apps and were
constantly upgrading this was actually a
great deal for example if you had
licenses to five Adobe apps that each
cost 700 and you upgraded them once
every five years you were spending at
thirty five hundred dollars every five
years and only getting access to five
apps at a fixed version with the
subscription on the other hand you would
not only be paying less at 3300 for real
five years but you would have access to
all of adobe's apps and always have the
latest version as well the problem
though was that the vast majority of
adobe's users didn't fall within this
category the average user only needed
one maybe two apps if we assume that
they upgraded it at the same frequency
of once every five years we're talking
about a fiber cost of 700 or 1400 and
that's only if they bought the whole
software again usually there were
upgrade options that cost 200 or 300
with the subscription model however they
now had to pay 3 300 for every five
years for little in return now you might
be thinking why not just get the
individual plants well the individual
plans are rip-offs and honestly I think
they simply exist to make the main plan
seem more attractive for example you can
either get 20 plus apps for 55 per month
or you can just get Photoshop or just
Premiere Pro for 21 one dollars per
month at those prices many of you are
probably thinking that it would just be
better to Pirate the software and for
hobbyists and Freelancers that might
make sense but for Pure professionals
and small companies that simply isn't an
option these people are in a weird
Middle Ground where they feel that the
software is overpriced but at the same
time their business is making too much
money for them to be dealing with the
Glitchy pirated software also if they
have significant skill they don't want
to risk getting sued by Adobe so they
have no choice but to reluctantly pay
the price and judging by adobe's
financials this is what most
professionals ended up doing in the last
8 years adobe's annual earnings have
skyrocketed from 200 to 300 million
dollars to roughly 5 billion dollars
mostly thanks to the new subscription
model but while this move worked out
great financially this move put off most
of adobe's customers many of them
started looking for Alternatives but the
reality is that there are no
alternatives for most Adobe apps sure
you've got options like DaVinci Resolve
Sony Vegas anacard Pro and a blender for
video editing but if you're looking for
things like Lightroom and illustrator
animate or photoshop you have no choice
but to go with Adobe I mean there's a
reason they control that 90 of the
market and now Adobe had turned on the
milking switch
now that adobe is making all this extra
money serving the same Market you would
think that they would amp up the
customer experience this means less bugs
fewer crashes better customer support
and a greater compatibility but the
company has actually been trending it in
the exact opposite direction ever since
they launched the subscription model
mostly because they just don't have to
care before the subscription model it
was essential that adobe made each
iteration as significant and impactful
as possible this was the only way that
they were gonna convince new users to
get a license or existing users to
upgrade their license with the
subscription model however Adobe has a
30 million users logged in depending it
every single month or every single year
regardless of whether the software
improves or not at the very least you
would hope that they would maintain a
certain bar but even that's not the case
with every new iteration of Windows Mac
OS and G views it seems like Adobe
software simply gets buggier and a
glitchier because they're not keeping up
with the changes and if you try to
contact them about these issues you're
probably going to be ignored it just
like all these people aside from letting
their software standards slip it seems
like Adobe has also let their ethical
standards slip for years Adobe was able
to just sit back and watch their income
figures go up as more and more people
reluctantly switched over but this
upward Trend it came to a harsh ended
during the pandemic basically everyone
who is on the fence about Adobe
capitulated and subscribed during the
pandemic in other words Adobe reached
Market saturation with their
subscriptions and their net income has
actually been flat for two years now
this isn't exactly a Bad Thing given
that they're making over a billion
dollars at every single quarter but as
you might have guessed they're looking
for more growth the easiest way to
accomplish this is to just in-tube
subscription prices and you can bet that
they've been doing that but they've also
turned to more unethical means in recent
times for example judging by reviews
there seems to be a trend of adobe
locking in free trial users into annual
subscriptions and when you try to cancel
your hit with a 100 to 150 termination
fee something else that's put off many
users is adobe's device limitations even
if you have a license you're only
allowed to authenticate two devices at
any given time but if you're a creative
professional you often use more than two
devices on a regular basis for example
you might have a main PC a Macbook a
Windows laptop and maybe an iPad but if
you want to use all these devices you'll
be regularly signing in and out and
authenticating and the authenticating
various devices this might sound like a
first world problem but let's not forget
that people are paying 600 every single
year for this software and they can't
even use it on all of their devices the
only reason that Adobe doesn't offer a
more generous device limit like 5 is to
get more people to sign up for their
commercial licenses which cost 85 per
month for each license so not only does
Adobe milk their customers but they
often do it in unethical ways
in stark contrast all of this Adobe is a
champion amongst employees and the
secret behind this is pretty simple they
treat employees at how they want to be
treated starting with offering an
extraordinary flexibility even before
the pandemic Adobe had strong remote and
hybrid work programs they also don't
micromanage any of their employees in
fact they don't even check if employees
are at work during traditional working
hours of course you might have to be
present at certain meetings at certain
times but other than that you're free to
create your own working schedule and
you'll be judged solely on results if
you're able to work it just 10 hours a
week and produce results that they're
happy with good for you aside from
giving employees Freedom Adobe also
makes employees feel valued by giving
them significant responsibility for
example they offer unlimited paid time
off because they trust that employees
have the best gauge of when and how much
time they need to take off they also
give employees significant Freedom
regarding what they work on but likely
the best example of adobe's
responsibility-driven culture is their
award-winning kickbox program this
program gives any staff member who
requests said a one thousand dollar
prepaid credit card to explore their
ideas no questions asked 1 000 employees
have used this program and that 23 of
these ideas ended up receiving it
further investment Adobe only has a
total of 25 000 employees meaning that 1
in 25 took this initiative and tried to
create larger impact all of this that
leads us to adobe's Core Company culture
value which is integrating up a
people-centric approach oftentimes one
of the top complaints at many companies
is that they don't recognize or
appreciate their employees but Adobe has
a robust Awards program that seeks to
recognize their best employees every
single year the most prestigious of
these Awards is the founders award which
is given to 12 people annually adopia
also takes is a great care when it comes
to encouraging diversity ensuring
paperity and creating transparency with
all these perks it's no wonder why Adobe
is so cherished by their employees
as we can see creating a great workplace
culture isn't rocket science it just
comes down to offering flexibility
Freedom responsibility and recognition
but ironically these are the exact
sectors in which Adobe is lacking when
it comes to their business
they don't offer customers any
flexibility or Freedom basically
everyone is forced to get the Creative
Cloud subscription similarly Adobe is
taking no responsibility when it comes
to maintaining refining and upgrading
the user experience and finally they're
not really recognizing or acknowledging
their customers they offer crappy
customer support and several legitimate
concerns are just outright ignored most
companies wouldn't not be able to get
away with such Behavior but given
adobe's Monopoly within creative
software they're able to do just about
anything and while there is a vocal
minority that tries to spread awareness
and is ditching Adobe for things like
Affinity photo the vast majority
unfortunately just don't care enough and
this includes myself as well do I think
Adobe software is overpriced yes
am I paying for 20 apps just to use
Premiere Pro and Photoshop yes but am I
gonna change no I'm simply used to Adobe
it and it gets the job done and the
price is not high enough for me to not
get it unfortunately this is the mindset
of most people in the space and that
this is what gave rise to the modern
Adobe that no one exactly loves it but
everyone uses anyway do you have an app
or service like this in your life
comment that down below also drop a like
if you wish all companies had adobe's
company culture and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community to
just for your video ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions I also
answered until then I'm Hari now see you
guys on the next one